s'il y a vraiment un danger à utiliser
ces produits là
il faut faire en sorte
j'ai aucune on préfère ne pas penser par
exemple où va le contenu de nos égouts
et je fais référence au solide en
particulier si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
[Musique]
réponse il y en a une partie qui est
épendue sur nos terres agricoles mais
est-ce qu'on sait vraiment tout ce qu'il
y a là-dedans on a fait équipe avec nos
collègues de la Semaine verte pour le
savoir
on commence à s'inquiéter des effets sur
notre santé puis sur la santé de
l'écosystème on est allé recueillir des
échantillons et on les a fait analyser
c'est clair que les contaminants dans
ces bons vont retourner dans
l'environnement directement
dans l'État du Maine on a récemment
interdit les pandage de fumier humain
parce qu'on trouve ça dangereux on est
allé dans le nord des États-Unis suivre
la route de ces produits et deviner quel
était leur destination ici Marie Maurice
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
Stone avec ses terres agricoles ces
animaux et ses fermes le coin de paradis
d'Armen rouge
[Musique]
bonjour toi
je suis arrivé ici avec mes parents à
1965 puis ensuite de ça
et demi j'ai jamais retourné à l'école
parce que j'étais mordu de l'agricole
tout va bien vous autres
je pense que la terre c'est elle qui m'a
permis d'avoir une vie que moi j'ai
apprécié
j'aime bien ça ici parce que c'est des
plus beaux coins du Québec je prêche
tout mon coin parce que c'est vrai c'est
un beau coin
mais le portrait c'est quelque peu
assombri il y a environ 10 ans j'ai
vendu une partie de mes terres c'est des
détails du long la rivière comme il faut
bien que sinon on est à chaque printemps
mais ces temps-là sont très productifs
mais la plus grosse partie est à l'autre
bout le nouveau propriétaire un
producteur de céréales décide d'épandre
des bio solides municipaux pour
fertiliser les champs
sur le terrain là-bas moi ça m'a fait
mal au cœur
des bouts d'épuration municipales une
catégorie de matière résiduelle
fertilisante de MRF
mais plus simplement il s'agit
d'excréments de fumier humain
[Musique]
qu'elle proviennent du réseau municipal
d'industrie ou de vidange de fosses
sceptiques les eaux usées sont traitées
dans les 800 stations de la province qui
purent l'eau le plus possible avant de
la rejeter dans des cours d'eau
les bouts sont le principal déchets
résultant de ce traitement pour les
éliminer il existe trois principales
options les enfouir les incinérer ou les
épandre dans des champs agricoles
plusieurs avantages ils sont riches en
azote en phosphore et en matière
organique sauf exception il est interdit
dans l'utiliser dans des champs
maraîchers ou destinés à l'alimentation
humaine
des compagnies de valorisation de MRF
font le lien entre l'usine d'épurations
et les champs agricoles au Québec les
deux principales entreprises sont
vERIDIS et englobe en général ce sont
elles qui sollicitent les agriculteurs
comme Armin
pour fertiliser nos chats c'est quoi
s
le secteur est régi par le guide sur le
recyclage des matières résiduelles
fertilisantes il y a des règles strictes
à respecter les agronomes embauchés par
les entreprises de valorisation de boue
se chargent de tout le volet
administratif
je m'en occupe c'est bien ça
[Musique]
les agronomes des compagnies produisent
eux-mêmes un plan agro-environnemental
de recyclage pour l'agriculteur et en
plus il rédige un avis de projet et le
soumettent au ministère de
l'Environnement le gouvernement a établi
des standards de surveillance pour
certaines substances toxiques il y a
certains critères au Québec on a
vraiment un cadre réglementaire assez
sophistiqué on surveille les
contaminants comme le plomb le nickel
cadmium l'arsenec quelques dioxines et
quelques furènes aussi qui sont des des
composés chimiques
tout ce qui est légumes c'est interdit
ok c'est correct bon ça veut dire que
vous faites du foin tout ça c'est bon de
foin céréales soya est-ce que je peux le
mettre aussi pour du soya que je suis
planifie de vendre sur le marché
consommation je peux te le mettre pareil
ok ça marche
que le monde devrait se réveiller quand
c'est pour une culture consommation
humaine on doit pas le mettre juste là
ça devrait réveiller
Sylvain Laroche est agronome à son
compte en Estrie il ne travaille pas
pour une compagnie de valorisation
depuis 18 ans il se spécialise en
agro-environnement environ 10% de sa
clientèle utilisent des MRF moi dans le
fond c'est certain client qui vont qui
ont été approchés par les compagnies qui
font de la bodarisation
les clients qui utilisent les MRF sont
surtout des producteurs agricoles
propriétaires de grandes superficie qui
n'ont pas accès à du fumier animal à
proximité ou qui n'en produisent pas
assez
l'inflation et la guerre en Ukraine ont
fait exploser le coût des fertilisants
les bouts offertes gratuitement
deviennent donc une option à l'échange
la demande en bio solide dépasserait
actuellement l'offre sur le marché
cette année il y a eu
et
envie d'en avoir un petit peu plus
[Musique]
le printemps et l'automne sont les
saisons de l'épandage les montagnes
debout s'accumulent dans les champs
de la route les amas attirent à peine
l'attention
[Musique]
vu des airs on constate leur ampleur
le ministère de l'Environnement observe
un intérêt grandissant pour les beaux
municipales il a recensé 220 projets en
421 en 2018 une augmentation de 45%
. OK
c'est quoi
parfois la transaction s'effectue
directement entre l'agriculteur et
l'agronome de la compagnie sans la vie
d'un deuxième agronome à son compte
comme Sylvain
neutre on est dans
la question la question se pose à
l'ordre puis il y a un dépôt
présentement par les membres de l'ordre
de
ministère de l'Environnement qui
autorise et qui surveille les activités
il fixe les balises pour éviter la
contamination de l'environnement mais il
analyse pas les bouts avant les pandage
la compagnie s'en charge le ministère
n'effectue pas de contre-vérification le
ministère enquête s'il reçoit des
plaintes du public après les pandage les
parallèlement à ce processus il effectue
ses propres vérifications
des documents que nous avons obtenus
démontre plusieurs fautes commises par
des agronomes
déclaration
échantillonnage effectué de manière
inadéquate et biaisée
dépassement hautement significatifs des
teneurs en nickel en molibènes en chrome
et en zinc
et bandage à moins de 50 m d'une maison
et bandage à 2,8 m d'un fossé et bandage
à 30 mètres d'un cours d'eau
et pendage à 100 mètres d'un puit de
consommation humaine
stockage de bio solide hors catégorie
pathogènes
en plus certains parmi eux ont été
inscrits au Registre des lobbyistes en
tant que promoteur debout tout en
demeurant à Grenoble
ça me décourage je souhaite il y a
encore des agronomes qui commencent de
la sorte il se laisse convaincre à dire
avec la bénédiction de l'environnement
que c'est correct mais ça sur des terres
agricoles ou ce qu'on produit du foin
dans des ingrédients
nous avons posé la question à la
présidente de l'Ordre des agronomes des
aspects de ça que j'apprends aujourd'hui
avec vous j'étais au courant est-ce que
c'est acceptable ou pas on peut se
questionner effectivement après
l'entrevue madame Giguère nous a fait
parvenir un complément de réponse la
notion d'acceptabilité sociale doit être
considérée l'ordre s'attend à ce que ses
membres fassent preuve de précaution et
évite à tout prix les situations de
conflit d'intérêts sous peine de
sanctions
[Musique]
en juillet 2022 l'Ordre des agronomes
aradié pendant deux mois un de ses
membres le Conseil de Discipline lui
reproche des manquements objectivement
grave et de s'être placé en conflit
d'intérêt ces rapports les tons dans le
jugement étaient truffés de mission
importantes de sorte que la protection
des cours d'eau des puits et des maisons
d'habitation voisine ont été mises en
péril ça craint précédent au niveau des
MRF pour l'Ordre des agronomes donc
c'est une décision qui est importante
mais il y a autre chose qui trouble
Sylvain Laroche
on voit analyser dans 20 ans ou des
trucs qu'on sait même pas qu'existe
c'est tout c'est toujours ça
après la pause le fumier humain est-ce
que c'est sécuritaire
au Québec on a peu ou pas de données sur
les teneurs des biocellites par rapport
au contaminant émergents de type
médicament hormone plastique PFR
[Musique]
partout sur la planète on s'intéresse de
plus en plus au pfas ce sont des
contaminants qui ont la particularité de
s'accumuler plutôt que de se dégrader et
le problème c'est qu'au Québec le
gouvernement ne s'est pratiquement rien
de ces contaminants dans les bouts
d'épuration municipales
que contient le fumier humain qu'on y
pense sur les terres agricoles
mon nom professionnel me demande de
protéger le public
s'il y a vraiment un danger à utiliser
ces produits là
il faut faire en sorte qu'ils se
retrouvent
pour le savoir nous nous rendons dans
les laboratoires de chimie
environnementales de l'Université de
Montréal
l'équipe du chercheur Sébastien sauvé se
penche notamment sur les composés
d'intérêt émergents dans ceux qu'on
retrouve dans les bio solides il y a les
données de par le monde mais au Québec
on a peu ou pas de données sur les
teneurs des biocellites par rapport aux
contaminants émergents de type
médicament hormone plastique PFS
le scientifique porte spécialement
attention au pfas des substances
chimiques d'intérêts émergents aussi
baptisé contaminant éternel les pff ont
s'y intéresse puis on s'inquiète parce
que justement elles sont très difficiles
à dégrader elle a donc reste très
longtemps dans l'environnement tendance
à se Biot accumuler ou à se concentrer
dans dans l'environnement dans la faune
et même chez les humains il y a des
effets chez l'humain bien documenté au
niveau
du métabolisme des gras donc d'un peu
causer problème de cholestérol avec les
problèmes cardiaques qui peuvent être
associés à ça il y a des problèmes au
niveau de la réponse immunologique donc
de développer une bonne réaction
d'immunisation pour un vaccin par
exemple et ça contribue à plusieurs
cancers et là on commence à s'inquiéter
des effets sur notre santé et puis sur
la santé de l'écosystème
nous sommes inconscients du taux que
c'est sa du taux de succeptions là dans
les biais solides et ensuite parce que
les biosélites peuvent s'accumuler dans
le sol et avec l'eau qui percole dans le
sol ça peut retourner dans les eaux
souterraines ça présente quand même un
danger important pour pour les humains
aussi pour les animaux et pour sur la
qualité de la végétation pour
l'alimentation humaine pour l'instant il
y a aucune norme il y a aucun camp de
réglementaire en ceci assez contaminants
d'intérêts émergents
nous avons montré les images à sabakan
l'avocate est spécialisée en droit
international de l’environnement son
expertise touche les lois liées aux
produits chimiques et aux déchets
c'est une c'est clair que les
contaminants dans ces bons vont
retourner dans l'environnement
directement et donc ça va juste
continuer le cirque le sacrifier de la
contamination
actuellement le gouvernement québécois
ne sait pratiquement rien sur la
présence de pfas dans les bouts
d'épuration de la province des
chercheurs ont rien de l’université de
Waterloo ont testé les bouts de 9
stations d'épuration du pays elle
contenait toutes des PHAs un tel
exercice n'a jamais été fait au Québec
première donnée qu'on a lu au labo pour
les biocellites sont toutes fraîches en
lien de les obtenir
[Musique]
pour notre enquête deux prélèvements ont
été effectués sur une des montagnes de
bout du Centre du Québec dont les odeurs
étaient fétides
[Musique]
on déplace un peu le taux le plus élevé
parmi les échantillons indiquent 118
partie par milliards
selon Sébastien sauvé première affaire
qui m'a sauté aux yeux dans les chiffres
c'est que on a effectivement dans les
deux bios solides les deux échantillons
de biocellulite qu'on avait il y a des
niveaux qui sont quand même pas
négligeables
le deuxième échantillon montre une
concentration de 71 partis par milliards
à ces niveaux là il y a clairement il y
a une source de pfas
dans l'eau usée qui arrive avec sa
station d'épuration là on sait pas doué
d'où vient ce temps-là c'est quoi
l'origine d'où ça vient
avec la collaboration de Sylvain Laroche
le chimiste a aussi prélevé des
échantillons chez un des clients de la
Grenoble qui utilisent des bio solides
la ferme est idéale pour l'exercice
des billes au solide ont été épendues
sur une partie des champs l'autre nom
une portion du troupeau de vaches à
consommer du foin qui a poussé dans un
champ fertilisé avec des bio solides et
l'autre non
les nouvelles ne sont pas réjouissantes
pour le client de Sylvain Laroche le
fumier des vaches nourrit avec un foin
sans bio solide afficher un taux de
0,84 parties par milliard
celui des vaches nourrit avec du foin
provenant du champ fertilisé au bio
solides et trois fois plus contaminés au
pfas
teaux on a trois fois plus de pfas
dans le fumier des vaches qui sont noués
avec un foin qui vient de suite on a
fait des épandages clairement il y a un
transfert et si il y a trois fois plus
de pfas dans le fumier de la vache faut
se rappeler que la vache est un système
d'intestin puis de digestion compliqué
et donc c'est clair que tout ce temps là
que les pfas sont ces estomacs puis dans
cette digestion il y a une absorption et
donc là on n'a pas tout mesuré s'il y
avait des résidus dans la viande dans le
lait etc avant ça je savais pas c'était
pas de quoi qu'on parlait
lui dire quoi votre client
puisque un petit nombre d'échantillons
ont été analysés il faut traiter ces
données avec précaution surtout avant de
mettre une hypothèse sur la
concentration de pfas dont le lait des
vaches et plus dans le long terme si on
a des sites qui ont reçu beaucoup plus
de BIOS solides ou si on a des fermes
qui produisent avec une source de
nourriture pour les animaux qui est
beaucoup plus concentré en PFS là il
pourrait y avoir peut-être un transfert
plus élevé donc faudrait vraiment
mesurer le lait
tout près d'ici au sud de la frontière
l'État du Maine a testé les pfas dans
l'eau les sols le fumier le lait des
vaches et le sang des producteurs
agricoles
à la lumière des résultats de cette
vaste enquête et en attendant de
connaître la meilleure façon de disposer
des bouts le gouvernement appliqué le
principe de précaution l'épandages des
bouts est dorénavant formellement
interdits et voilà que ces bouts sont
maintenant détournés vers le Québec
au retour on va suivre un camion en
provenance des États-Unis et découvrir
que le libre-échange ça s'applique aussi
à ces matières
tout est fait selon les normes ça veut
dire que c'est au ministère de se
réveiller
[Musique]
récemment l'état du main a décidé
d'interdire les pendages de bio solide
sur son territoire alors là ils sont
pris avec tout un problème l'état
s'accumule ils savent plus quoi en faire
il veut s'en débarrasser alors ils ont
trouvé une solution en envoyant une
partie chez nous
[Musique]
les étangs de Sainte-Foy le repère de
plus de 200 espèces d'oiseaux ils
attirent des ornithologues des quatre
coins du Maine oui
Brousseau est particulièrement fier des
étangs d'aération il gère la station
d'épuration des eaux usées de la
municipalité située dans le sud de
l'Etat
mais juste à côté des réservoirs d'eau
les problèmes sans piles
il ne peut plus disposer des bouts
d'épuration à des fins de fertilisation
même si la rétrocaveuse tente de
maximiser l'espace le site
d'enfouissement déborde
au cours des dernières années pour
éviter que les sites d'enfouissement ne
se remplissent trop vite la municipalité
a investi près de 2 millions de dollars
pour produire un compost à partir de ces
bouts le produit est évendu à des
agriculteurs des paysagistes des villes
ou des particuliers voilà que la
montagne de compost ne fait maintenant
que grossir
les résultats ont montré que nous avions
des produits chimiques éternels dans
notre compost
André Brousseau a fait tester son
compost il révèle la présence de pfas
même si les bouts ont été mélangés avec
d'autres matières notamment des cendres
de bois le Maine interdit toute
utilisation de bio solide ou de compost
fait à partir de bout d'épuration le
gestionnaire de la station est des
dizaines d'autres comme lui par tout
dans l'État sont au prises avec le même
problème les goûts s'accumulent et ils
doivent tous s'en débarrasser
notre seule option est le dépotoir on ne
peut pas les peindre
le problème
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de site
d'enfouissement autorisé près d'ici
évidemment nous avons celui qui se
trouve derrière ce bâtiment mais il est
à pleine capacité
une lettre adressée à un de ses
gestionnaires dont nous avons obtenu
copie on dit davantage sur les impacts
de cette décision la compagnie cassella
une des plus grosses entreprises
américaines de valorisation de bio
solides explique que la nouvelle
réglementation du Maine la force sera à
développer de nouveaux marchés pour son
compost notamment le marché canadien
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne l'échange commercial
alors les échanges transcontraliens il y
a pas de règles ou de limites sur le
commerce des bio solide parce que même
s'ils sont faites à partir des déchets
municipaux ils sont considérés des
produits et non pas des déchets alors ce
sont pas des produits qui sont
réglementés comme des substances
hasardeuses ou des déchets hasardeux
après l'interdiction dans le Main André
Brousseau a reçu une proposition venant
du Québec
sords sur des œufs pique-nides
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'autre bouée de sauvetage c'est
l'entreprise RMI un partenaire américain
d'englobe aussi spécialisé dans la
valorisation de bio solides
ils viennent à nous installations à New
Hampton dans le New Hamp sheer si vous
regardez l'autoroute 93 nous sommes en
plein milieu et puis ça monte jusqu'au
Canada
des stations d'épuration du Maine
détournent maintenant leur bout vers le
centre de traitement du New Hampshire
nous ne faisons pas le transport vers le
Canada notre entreprise le sous-traitent
ils sont donc responsables du transport
du passage de la frontière et de la
conformité de la livraison
grâce aux informations que nous avons
obtenues nous avons pu localiser un
camion d'une compagnie de transport
canadienne sous-traitante dans globe qui
arrive du New Hampshire à la douane de
Stan stades
dans le cas de notre activité vers le
Canada nous faisons peut-être 4 à 5
chargements par semaine selon la semaine
chaque fois ce serait 30 tonnes de
matière
une partie de la matière que nous avons
détournée vers le Canada sera épendu sur
les terres et profitera aux agriculteurs
canadiens ces merveilleux
[Musique]
c'est ici à Bury en Estrie que le même
camion celui que nous avons suivi des
verse sa cargaison
[Musique]
englobe nous a ouvert les portes de son
site de compostage contrairement à ce
que rapporte RMI englobation que les
baux municipales américaines ne sont pas
répandues dans les champs agricoles on
n'aurait pas assez de notre propre
fumier humain à gérer sans avoir à gérer
celui des Américains
c'est une belle matière ok je trouvais
que le bio solide comme je vous explique
ce qui proviennent du Canada des
États-Unis c'est un bio solide donc à la
base c'est la même chose qu'il faut
faire c'est s'assurer que le biosolite
qui pourrait compter être contaminés que
des niveaux élevés de pie face viennent
pas ici avec les bio solides municipaux
des États-Unis englobe produit du
compost qui se retrouve ailleurs dans
l'environnement on va faire un produit
fini qui peut être soit du compost
pur ou des Terreaux qui en fait un on va
ajouter certains ingrédients au compost
pour en faire des
pour du paysagement ou du gazon ou autre
chose si on a quelque chose qui est
déconcentrations très élevé dans ce qui
nous arrive qui est mélangé avec du
compost propre on a contaminé du compte
du compost propre puis là on peut avoir
un problème fort il faut mesurer on peut
pas juste diluer sans mesurer il faut
qu'on sache
le problème c'est que si en ce moment il
y a pas de seuil ou de critères pour
définir qu'est-ce qui est propre pour
les pfas
peut pas savoir j'ai pas de bio solide
municipaux qui sont étendues dans les
champs on a des certaines bouts de
projets papetti qui ont aucunement du
pie face qui sont effectivement envoyés
à l'agricole
au centre
du capital livré par anglobe celui que
nous avons testé et qui affiché un taux
jusqu'à 118 parties par milliard de pfas
la matière a été épendue et l'affiche en
bordure de la route affirme qu'il s'agit
debout de projets pas petit elle
viendrait du Québec selon englobe
bien illégal car au Canada et au Québec
il n'existe aucune loi qui encadre la
présence de pfas dans les bio solides
tout est fait selon les normes ça veut
dire que c'est au ministère de se
réveiller moi comme simple citoyen
puisa des sérieuses questions
ou à l'efficacité du ministère de voir
ou bien de sa population
dans ce contexte englobe
s'auto-règlemente un laboratoire
certifié qu'elle engage test
systématiquement les sources de bout
américaine ce qu’elle appelle des
gisements et ce pour 22 types de PFS de
façon ponctuelle l'entreprise vérifie
les concentrations de pfas pour les
bouts du Québec
on est proactif et on veut s'assurer le
congend bien la matière et on va prendre
des tests du gisement ce qu'on appelle
le gisement avant même de les recevoir
pour entre autres évaluer les teneurs en
piface et
assurer que c'est des gisements qui sont
propices à être su quand les
gisements vont que vous vous êtes
autour de dictée
on travaille avec des spécialistes dans
le domaine et qui on est très prudent
donc il y a des niveaux qui qui se
rapprochent de ce que le Main n'avait
fait qui est deux points 5 ppb
ppb ce sont les parties par milliards
avant un interdiction le gouvernement du
Maine réglementait deux types de PFS les
PFOA dont la limite était fixée à 2,5
parties par milliards et les PFOS
limitées à 5,2 parties par milliards les
résultats de Sébastien sauvés sur Lama
qui provient d'anglobe et que nous avons
testé des montres que ces bouts sont
jusqu’à 5 fois plus concentrés en PFOA
et jusqu'à 6 fois plus concentré en PFOS
que les anciens standards du Maine
dans un courriel englobe se dit étonné
par ses résultats car leur propre
données n'arrivent pas à ce constat
pour les boue d'ici ou celle du Main
Louis côté soutient que la valorisation
demeure une option verte
[Musique]
pourquoi je me priverais de cette
matière là que des telles propriétés et
qui permet des sauver l'enfouissement ça
contribue à la santé des sols gaz à
diminution gaz à effet de serre et tout
ça et qu'on élimine des engrais
peut-être chimiques c'est clair que les
pfas sont un enjeu environnemental
majeur on peut pas le nier un petit
certainement un retard pour réglementer
puis mettre des normes et des critères
clairs mais là il y a une urgence parce
que si un transfert de pollution puis
qu'on est on va être pris avec les
problèmes que le Maine avait parce qu'on
laisse faire et on des problèmes aux
États-Unis avec ce composé là
après la pause est-ce que le Québec est
en train de devenir la toilette de
certains États américains
[Musique]
on pourrait croire que le ministère de
l'environnement dont la mission est de
nous protéger c'est clairement ce qui
traverse la frontière mais vous allez
voir que d'une communication à l'autre
les réponses sont assez confuses
[Musique]
le pont ambassadeur le lien entre
Détroit et Windsor la route des camions
de bio solide entre le Michigan et
l'Ontario
l'an dernier 70 000 tonnes de boue ont
été exportés au Canada
et la spécialiste des substances
toxiques pour le Sierra Club au Michigan
selon l'association écologiste plus de
2300 camions chargés debout traverserait
la frontière ontarienne chaque année
l'équivalent de 6 camions par jour
etiennement des questions oui je me
préoccuperai du fait que cette matière
passe la frontière
je serais inquiète
je me demandais ce qui se passe dans mon
pays
le Michigan est l'un des principaux
états industriels des États-Unis c'est
notamment ici que les PFA trouvent leur
origine
on y trouve des activités de raffinage
pétrolier l'industrie du caoutchouc et
des matières plastiques des papiers
est plus connu aux États-Unis
le Maine et certains États du Nord-Est
le main et le seul État jusqu'ici à
avoir interdit totalement les pandages
debout le Michigan et le seul autre à
surveiller étroitement les pfas dans les
bio solides et sur les fermes mais son
approche est différente de celle du
Maine en deçà de 20 parties par milliard
de PFOS l'épandage est permis ces quatre
fois plus que le seuil limite de l'État
du Maine avant l'interdiction et c'est
le standard que souhaitant globe pour le
Québec
il y a d'autres endroits comme le
Michigan qui sont en train de travailler
d'autres types de positionnement parce
que il y a un bénéfice à utiliser puis
présentement on se positionne très bas
pour apprendre puis s'assurer qu'on
qu'on met pas personne en danger
[Musique]
avant de se mettre à suivre la trace des
bio solides pour le Sierra Club Denise
strabic porter a travaillé pendant 42
ans pour un émetteur de pfas le géant
américain de la chimie Dupont la justice
américaine a condamné Dupont dans le
milieu des années 2000 pour avoir caché
des informations sur la toxicité des
produits utilisés dans le téflon cette
saga des pfas lui a fait faire ce virage
à 180 degrés j'ai des amis de Dupont sur
Facebook qui m'ont écrit que j'avais
rejoint le côté obscur et j'ai répondu
que c'était peut-être l'inverse
au Québec nous avons voulu avoir des
explications du ministère de
l'environnement ni le Ministre Benoît
charrette ni le ministère n'ont voulu
nous accorder d'entrevue cependant avant
notre enquête une fonctionnaire du
ministère a répondu aux questions de nos
collègues de l'émission La semaine verte
sur la possibilité que c'est beau
traversent la frontière
donc là on n'a pas été mis au courant
qui est une volonté d'importation
spécifiquement de ces boules par
définition vous serez pas les premiers
au courant je me sens on est quand même
souvent mis au courant
quand un globe la compagnie a refusé de
dévoiler les quantités importées au
Québec
des informations qui sont compétitives
donc je vais aller garder pour moi
peut-être juste m'énumérer les endroits
où d'où viennent les bouts américaines
c'est des contrats encore là que j'ai de
commercial et qui sont confidentielles
donc ça aussi je vais le garder pour moi
mais il n'y a pas que le main nous avons
découvert que le New hamps le
Massachusetts le Vermont et New York
exporte aussi des bio solides au Québec
pour moi ce qui est un peu aberrant
c'est une imaginez qu'il y a des bouts
d'épurations qui arrivent des États-Unis
sans être documenté le gouvernement ne
détient que des données très partiels
sur les volumes de bio solide importé
c'est pas réglementé il y a aucune façon
il y a aucune suivie ou obligation de
rapporter des transferts au gouvernement
alors c'est très normal que le
gouvernement québécois n'a aucune idée
de
ces quantités là
des biosolède municipaux et conservés
par l'exploitant au sein de registre
selon le ministère de l'Environnement
Québec doit donc frapper à la porte des
entreprises pour savoir d'où ces
biocelyne et quelle est la quantité
exacte de boue ou de compost importer
des États-Unis englobe veut collaborer
et dissouetter un cadre réglementaire
mieux défini
on souhaite
parce que on fait les bonnes choses mais
on va travailler avec les gens du
ministère pour partager ce que nous on
sait
mais pour ceux sur le terrain il y a
urgence d'agir
[Musique]
correct mais pas ça chez nous mais je
mets ça ailleurs
à ce moment-là la moralité je trouve que
si c'est pas bon pour moi pourquoi que
je le mettrais sur la taille d'un autre
[Musique]
je pense qu'il faut se questionner puis
il faut revenir à
je pense que à l'importance là puis que
le gouvernement légifère puis qui nous
donne des outils réglementaires Québec
nous a aussi répondu qu'il réalise
actuellement un projet de recherche sur
les contaminants des terrains émergents
dans les bio solides municipaux et
pendant ce temps
Ottawa compte publié en 2023 un rapport
sur la situation des pfas le
gouvernement fédéral pourrait
restreindre l'utilisation des pfas
on continue pourquoi on a peut-être pas
le principe de précaution pour que les
gens le demandent faut que la
volonté des gens de mettre la pression
sur nos politiciens nos politiciens vont
bouger mais là c'est vraiment une
question politique le la science pour
démontrer qu'il y a des problèmes elle
est très claire
ce qui est pas clair en ce moment c'est
comment on établit les seuils donc là il
faut faudrait peut-être agir de façon un
peu plus Prévent vous par principe de
précaution pour faire des normes
rapidement
[Musique]
c'est comme très urgent
c'est clair que les pfas sont un enjeu
environnemental majeur on peut pas le
nier il faut bouger vite sinon on fait
de l'expérimentation à grande échelle
chez nous dans un coup
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié notre
enquête de ce soir je vous invite
également à regarder le reportage de nos
collègues de la Semaine verte qui ont
travaillé sur le même sujet c'est tout
pour nous au nom de toute l'équipe merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour
une autre enquête
[Musique]